françois après ce contenu bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors le monde a les yeux rivés sur les
résultats de cette élection
quelle est l'importance de ce scrutin à
l'international bien ce scrutin est à la
fois important et un peu plus à
relativiser par rapport aux précédents
terre que bien sûr les etats-unis ont
toujours ce rôle moteur ce rôle
essentiel de référence dans les
relations internationales
mais pour reprendre l'expression de la
famille française affaires étrangères
hubert védrine
ils sont plus aujourd'hui le
l'hyperpuissance qui décide de tout
comme elle le faisait ya trente ans au
moment de la chute du mur de berlin
aujourd'hui la les etats unis doivent
compter avec la chine avec la russie y
voir avec l'inde ou d'autres pays qui
monte en puissance
néanmoins je pense je ne pense pas qu'il
y aura de grandes variations selon le
président qui sera élu pour plusieurs
raisons c'est que donald trump et les
craintes qui continuera un peu ça marche
on en refusant de ce qu'on appelle le
multilatéralisme et en se présentant
comme avant tout les défenseurs les
états unis alors quant à joe biden on a
un certain nombre d'incertitudes
notamment sur ses capacités peut-être
personnel à gérer voire en effet quelle
sera la machine démocrate qui sera qui
sera derrière lui et on peut
s'interroger également sur le fait s'il
aura la capacité ou la volonté même de
reprendre un peu la main dans une
politique plus volontariste mais à
risque tel que l'avait conduite
l'administration obama avec notamment
hillary clinton à la tête de cette
diplomatie
l'arrivée de donald trump à la maison
blanche il ya quatre ans avait surpris
tout le monde qu'on a été pris de court
puisque les sondages donnent et hillary
clinton
grande favorite on a découvert un
personnage bien différent des anciens
présidents américains avec un franc
parler parfois assez direct
président américain qui twitte à tout va
on a vu aussi que il avait vraiment
balayée d'un revers tous les traités qui
avaient été signés tout cela est fait
barack obama finalement donald trump a
essayé de le découvre petit à petit des
sanctions financières qui ont été
imposées vis-à-vis de certains pays une
guerre commerciale avec la chine alors
est ce que finalement quoi qu'il arrive
que ça soit donald trump ou joe biden
donald trump va laisser son empreinte
sur les relations internationales
oui et non non parce que je pense que
non l'incertain deux mesures parce que
sur certains dossiers les états unis
sont quelque peu en retrait sur le
prochain il ya certes l'accord abraham
spectaculaire puisque les émirats arabes
unis bahreïn et récemment le soudan ont
signé un accord de paix avec israël mais
néanmoins sur les volets les plus
sensibles la méditerranée orientale de
la libye la syrie où les avancées de la
turquie les états unis sont relativement
absents par contre une chose qui est
fondamental je pense que donald trump a
a eu à peut-être en train avoir deux
trains avance sur la future
configuration des relations
internationales c'est à dire que la
guerre commerciale avec la chine
c'est ni plus ni moins le fait que dc
d'entraver la marche vers le leadership
mondial de la chine trains n'ont pas
bien compris une chose c'est que la
puissance de la chine telle quelle elle
s'était projeté depuis une vingtaine
d'années sur la scène internationale
elle provient avant tout de ses
gigantesques excédents commerciaux et
très bas bien compris que c'était le
talon d'achille d'achille de la chine si
l'on peut dire est qu'il fallait couper
le robinet des excédents commerciaux et
ensuite des excédents financiers et
budgétaires pour que la chine justement
n'est plus est cette avancée stratégique
alors là il faudra il faudra voir un peu
comment baydan s'il est élu réagir et
par rapport à la chine
en sachant que c'est aujourd'hui la
pierre angulaire qui se dessine pour les
les relations internationales à venir
dans pour les intérêts en tout cas
américain alors on ne sait pas encore
bien évidemment comment réagir et joe
biden s'il était président d
etats unis face à la chine ou en tout
cas où la russie on sait que la veille
de l'élection présidentielle le candidat
démocrate a qualifié moscou 2 principal
ennemi et pékin de grand rival
d'ailleurs vous allez rester avec nous
monsieur constantini mais on sait que la
question d'une éventuelle ingérence
russe et revient à chaque élection
présidentielle elle est revenu notamment
durant ces élections américaines
écoute à ce sujet le point de vue du
sénateur russe aleksei guskov le
président de la commission de
l'information et des médias vous savez
aux états unis il est très difficile de
comprendre qui serait meilleur
par exemple pour la russie du point de
vue politique donc ça vraiment une
ingérence peut être considéré
théoriquement moins quand il ya un doute
aux etats unis une agence n'a pas de but
et donc je ne vois aussi aucune preuve
de cette agence et le fait qu'on parle
de moins en moins ni la lier times ni le
washington post
ni la cncc dans média libéral a qui sont
des médias et nos partisans
ils sont ils sont tous du côté de baden
il ne parle soudainement plus de
l'ingérence russe et je pense que la
raison c'est que ben laden est en train
de gagner l'élection gagner l'élection
mais en tout cas regardez n'est apte et
puisqu'on attend encore les résultats
définitifs
monsieur constantini la russie c'est
l'ennemi par par défaut depuis je pense
que c'est une écurie erronée que font
les états unis lecture café george
deubeuliou bush à la suite
quelques années après la loi en
septembre où il a qualifié la russie des
nues stratégique
je pense que la russie est qualifiée d'
ennemi stratégique pour une raison c'est
que les états unis ne veulent pas
d'unité à l'ensemble de la lèche l
ensemble du continent européen
ils veulent pas d'une grande europe unie
dans laquelle la russie sur un
partenaire stratégique politique
diplomatique économique énergétique
de premier plan pour l'union européenne
par exemple ils font tout pour casser en
effet cette cette grande entente cons
continental c'est ce que j'appelle la
doctrine brésil ce qui est du nom de ce
bingo de résine ski qui était l'ancien
conseiller de jimmy carter d'origine
polonaise qui dans son livre le grand
échiquier dit bien qu'il faut casser en
effet tout entendre continental
intercontinental européenne etc en effet
cette grande europe pourraient menacer
les etats-unis leur leadership leur
contesteraient en quelque sorte lors le
ron paul de leur premier pôle de
référence au plan international je pense
qu'il s'agit d'une erreur des états unis
quant à la question d'ingérence c'est
une douce plaisanterie et l'ingérence à
vous à dire que la russie ou le kremlin
depuis en effet une une machine
tentaculaire je ne sais quoi dirigerait
les électeurs américains
non mais tout ça tout ça prête à
prêterait au comique si ce n'était pas
porté par des dirigeants de premier plan
notamment du parti démocrate
alors oui je pense que désigné la russie
comme ennemi c'est tout simplement aller
dans un sens de la stratégie américaine
qui ne veulent pas d'une grande ni d'une
grande europe qui seraient ils n'ont pas
contre elle mais qui serait une rivale
justement est ce que la présidence de
donald trump a accentué les divergences
entre les états unis et l'europe bien je
pense que en effet les donald tromper
quelqu'un qui défend les intérêts des
états unis les défendez fosse au
détriment des européens notamment sur le
secteur automobile encore que donald
trump il faut quand même le souligner
est quelqu'un qui est un ami un terme
aux négociations du traité
transatlantique du taffetas et ensuite
qui a décidé que si les négociations
commerciales devait reprendre on
retirait le secteur l'agriculture ce qui
est plutôt un bienfait d'ailleurs pour
les pour les agriculteurs européens en
général et françaises et français en
particulier
je pense qu'aujourd'hui bizarrement ce
sont les européens qui ont des positions
les plus maximaliste à l'égard de la
russie les plus hostiles
trump a en effet continué en quelque
sorte n'a pas notamment retisser les
liens avec là aussi comme on aurait pu
le plus s'y attendre
par rapport aux égards ces déclarations
la campagne de 2016 mais on est frais il
ya une divergence en effet d'intérêts
entre donald trump et les européens et
on voit en effet que donald trump par
exemple ensuite sur le plan stratégique
on voit que donald trump sur se voit
voit que sur sur l'otan par exemple eh
bien ne fait pas de l'otan en tout cas
l'outil de sa stratégie préférentiels
concernant les relations avec la france
tout au début à son arrivée à la maison
blanche convoyer une sorte
voilà de proximité entre emmanuel macron
et donald trump
après voilà les relations se sont un
petit peu dégradée comment est ce que
vous voyez justement les relations
concernant paris et washington dans le
cas où joe biden deviendrait président
des états unis est ce qu'on va rester
sur la même ligne où il n'y aura un
changement de politique selon vous il y
aura peut-être en changeant de la
caution il y aura peut-être en effet
rousset en france la présidence
française sa tâche de façon très
pratiquement monôme quasiment
monomaniaque à l'accord de paris sur le
climat donc en effet un éventuel retour
des des états unis dans la dans l'accord
de paris sur le sur le climat 2015
améliorer les relations mais c'est quand
même pas le pas plus qu'une hirondelle a
fait le printemps c'est quand même pas
le l'histoire du climat ensuite aussi
contestable que puissent être les cela
dit en passant les les clauses de
l'accord de l'accord de paris tant du
fait des des analyses que dès que des
solutions proposées
c'est pas quand même le climat qui va
qui va refaire qui va reprendre une
diplomatie même si certains aujourd'hui
voudraient en faire la pierre angulaire
quant aux rivalités commerciales
existeront toujours les intérêts
européens américains sont sondés plus
divergents et on voit pas même une
administration démocrate
aujourd'hui être plus conciliante à
l'égard de l'union européenne sur les
questions économiques et commerciales
au vu de la situation actuelle est de 7
gestion catastrophique de la pandémie de
coronavirus qui a fait énormément de mal
aux américains une amérique divisé
scindé en deux est-ce que voilà elle
aura toujours sa place dans le premier
rang mondial en termes de puissance mais
vous savez c'est toute la question je
pense que on a beaucoup poussé certaines
zones sur son livre sur le choc des
civilisations mais n'at on a peu oublié
son dernier qui était en quelque sorte
son livre testament sap et au cou et or
qui sommes nous en fait qui était une
interrogation sur l'identité américaine
je veux dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont moi je pense qu'avec ce qu'on a vu
ces derniers - le mouvement blacksite
moiteur et les oppositions
je pense que les etats unis sont de
façon virtuelle mais et larvée dans une
quasi guerre de sécession à terme c'est
à dire que vous avez une polarisation il
faut écrire en effet une politisation
entre eux entre deux peuples et entres
des ce qu'on appelait des minorités
ethniques qui sont plus en plus
importantes qui sont rangés singulière
boucle
du côté des démocrates et on avait fait
une fracture américaines atypiques
politique sociale sociaux le
sociologique culturelle également qui
est en train de traverser de traverser
le pays est en effet c'est un pays où il
ya le de moins en moins d'unités
c'est un pays où en effet le leadership
mondial est contestée du moins est remis
en question du fait de logique interne
de problématiques internes qui
reprendrait le qui reprendrait le devant
et je pense que c'est tout là
l'ambiguïté du north american avec un
pays qui veut jouer à la fois le rôle
d'état montrent de référence mais un
pays dont on voit que la composante
populaire la composante populaire est en
train de changer et qui ou en quelque
sorte un certain de fractures internes
et je pense que ce sont les questions
peut-être sur lesquels les hadjis se
pencheront le plus dans les années à
venir
merci beaucoup françois costantini
d'avoir réagi ce matin sur rtl que vous
êtes docteur en sciences politiques et
spécialiste des relations à
l'international